I am very fascinated by chess.
Not just because I was playing in middle school.
Or participated in the competition in high school.
It’s not a trophy at college.
The chess is wonderful because it has a lot of meaning in the movie.
Whether through metaphor, metaphor, or storyline
Producers like to add chess to the story to present something that other games can’t show.
So let's get started!
1: If you want to learn, I will teach you 2: Hey, please, we are still comparing.
Basically, chess is used as a metaphor
It is often associated with "patience" and "precision"
Is boxing a kind of chess known? You must choose tactics to kill each other.
The main character in the interstellar terminator is set as a chess player.
He referenced the chess in the whole movie.
A is like chess
First you have to strategically locate these pieces.
When the time is right, they will fight each other.
The next step is to use chess to show someone's cleverness.
Here is where the director cleverly uses it.
In 2001: Space roaming, Hal's intelligence is based on the ability to defeat humans in chess.
For the current movie fans, this scene has lost its importance.
Because in the past 20 years, computers have been defeating humans.
But in 1968, this scene shows that Hal not only has high IQ, but is also very powerful.
If you look at this scene more closely, it is actually a layman of some important episodes.
When this super computer tells humans a better choice
Hal: I am sorry, Frank, I think you missed it.
The queen moved to the bishop 3, the bishop ate the queen
The Cavaliers eat the bishop
From the chess we see that the computer does not agree with humans.
And moved a better step for him, subtly showing that the computer can touch and surpass him.
This scene has been very well laid out for the storyline.
I am sorry, Dave. I am afraid I can't do this.
Hal actually made a mistake when talking about the game.
His chess advice, the Queen moved to Bishop 3, is impossible
So Hal execution was forced to die, but was wrongly announced
You can say that it is the fault of Cooper.
Or, more interestingly, it is Kubrick's subtlety that paves the way for Harr's final disintegration.
Hal and Frank's showdown brought to the third point
Chess can skillfully present a confrontation between two people.
This can be what you think is symbolic or just trivial.
In Sherlock Holmes, the actual conflict in the chess game made this meaning more obvious.
This is a dispute of wisdom, but there are other implications for this matchup.
Chess is a very versatile game, Pixar has made a short story about the chess
It’s like saying that it’s common to show someone’s sacrifice with chess.
Perhaps the most "literal" example is Harry Potter.
Knight moved to H3
Sherlock Holmes sacrificed his queen in the game, directly reflecting his intention to stop Moriarty’s plan.
The strategy of victory sometimes needs to be sacrificed
Think further, you can even let the chess pieces metaphorize what will happen.
Wan Wang Wang played the car and the Cavaliers, but Professor X sacrificed the powerful chess.
And pawn to win
These moves reflect the worldview of each player
Wan Wang has a strong chess to represent the struggle with the mutant
However, Professor X showed his trust in humanity and the desire for cooperation with his paws.
This scene is a clever metaphor for the movie, because the pawn in the chess can be transformed into a knight or a car.
When human beings are used as pawns in X-Men movies, this metaphor will be strongly supported.
In chess, the pawn moves first.
I think the chess game metaphor is very powerful in the story.
In the American crime story, Laubert Shapiro and Johnny Carson both placed chess in the office.
In this episode they decided to debate the race
In this scene, the chess is placed on the right side of the foreground.
From this it is obvious that the chess is shifted to the lens focus.
And what do I think this might represent?
Of course, I hesitate to over-interpret, but if the chess is only a war of black and white, it is meaningless.
In this scene about black white dialogue, chess has a powerful visual effect.
And added that this trial is about racial meaning
Perhaps the best summary of using all of these techniques comes from the scene of the TV series FireWire Crime Squad.
Daniel essentially uses chess to explain drug trafficking
The car is a poison cave, the queen is an accomplice, and the king is the head.
They even took the names of gangs on the pieces.
He won’t panic
The people in this gang cover him.
They are blocking, he doesn’t have to do anything at all.
Just like your uncle
Right like my uncle
The pawn is compared to a soldier. In reality, these children are small soldiers in the gang.
So they naturally agree with the pawn identity.
Interesting is the question raised by Florus after understanding the pawn.
They like to rush to the front, on the battlefield
Then how do you become a king?
not like this
Look, the king is always the king.
Alright? No one will change.
The pawn will always serve the king, no matter how
Even walking across the board
If you caught the other king
Then set the trap, then you win.
Ok, but if I stay until the end
I am the head
This is not the case
From chess, we learned about drug friendship and how his class hierarchy is consolidated like a flag.
In any case, these pieces are bound by their identity, nowhere to escape.
They sacrificed for the king, but they will never be in power anyway.
These pawns, dude, will soon be caught in the trick.
"Game" will end soon
Unless they are a small pawn
Most games are linear in the use of the movie.
Bingo builds on family life after retirement
If you are playing dungeons and dragons, then the character is the stereotype of the nerd.
But if it is chess, there is always more worth analyzing.
So try to take the first step
Where is your majesty?
Hi, sir, the king is playing chess.
chess?
I hate chess!
Thanks for watching!